[Musique]
3h45 c'est lors du premier café au
centre d'exploitation du groupe suez al
ahmar tous les matins 13 camions
poubelles partout d'ici vers tous les
quartiers de sainte-marie et
sainte-suzanne parti voit la matinée
michel boutin était bauer depuis plus de
20 ans privilège des anciens il ne
ramasse plus les poubelles il conduit le
camion
c'est yannick et jean-denis les rippeurs
qui seront à la manoeuvre ce matin
qui pour une
combien d'heures de récolte a laissé
tête en bas c'était ton collègue avec
une pause de 20 minutes pour un aspect
de fons
oui c'est l'habitude la routine quoi
et c'est parti direction la marine à
sainte-suzanne avant commune angot et
commune carron pendant toute la matinée
yannick et jean denis vont répéter les
mêmes gestes oh my back bien en avant
comme ça dans l'es3
mais accrocheur on regarde ça tombe mal
au foot on peut le faire monter
un coup de vent euros 206 est calme
c'est quand même mais les gens adorent
les gens ils pas trop de circulation
mais après le problème la danse sont
léchés et on est tous ces parcours
agréable quoi mais c'est un camion
équipé d'un valet d'une pelle donc pour
les gens nouvelle ne fait le ramassage
moi tout le monde est content le chien
fait son travail
oh mon dieu les poneys ça vous fait le
sale boulot j'en faut pas dire faut pas
dire ça comme ça mais je devrai qu' il
fallait pas le temps pas pour le chien
mais c'est un sale boulot voilà c'est un
métier comme les autres comme un dieu ça
tourne à droite car là bas
pour faire ce métier là il faut avoir le
bon tempo et ne pas rater la marche et
ça ce n'est pas à la portée de tout le
monde
en revanche les mauvaises odeurs ne
semble pas être un problème beaucoup
moins par ailleurs
entre jeunes on mai après que l'otan je
peux lire les futurs en été ah oui il
était venu à pendant fédérale 2 pi ca y
est après midi au delà des trucs que je
m'adapte ballets sont pas vraiment bon
voir depuis combien de temps on fait ça
depuis huit ans et au final nous aime ça
au final abidjan - les meilleur e
on travaille là dessus on rencontre des
gens et tout le pack ouais c'est comme
un âne entreprises auront sur le banc
fait mais de la bonne dame l'extérieur
le monde les gens et des femmes ne
voulaient pas des taxes l'image fait-il
à 2 min travail s'est elle demandée
parce que t'es où ils bougent année tout
ça allait mieux comprendre comment les
voyez que coller derrière la mêlée
couler ce côté n'est pas pareil l'audi
appareils sont moins cool et d y est que
le sco tes fans un camarade jean marc et
moi tu es comme ça mais là dessus tb
tu arrives la fin du mois comme sur le
coup
[Musique]
un soleil d'hiver tullaye lèvres
avec les jours
[Musique]
donc à nous presque finie la marine
[Rires]
c'est la caméra là ici la ca c
la sécurité c'est à dire que la caméra
de deïr que me faire l'équipe en vieille
à travailler ici miron la charia que les
gars aient sciemment acheté le camion
distance directement
maintenant où elle ce métier
[Musique]
c'est ma vie en
quand on voit tout ça
de money jettent n'importe quoi ah oui
en fait même pas le tir vous tenez dans
les bonnes bonnes nouvelles dont il
capte une médaille belle grille les plus
vite et vous autres
[Musique]
et là l'endroit nous pour les nounous
très jeune et le matin vous êtes filmés
pendant la pause
nous évoquons une enquête parue
récemment sur le travail des éboueurs à
paris dans la capitale ils sont souvent
insulter menacer
il n'est pas rare qu'on leur lance des
gages espèce de fainéants espèce de bons
à rien
ici on n'a pas ce genre de réaction non
non jamais jamais franchement jamais des
gens qui arrivent comme sa collègue
légion
bartoli
c'est plus cool à la réunion des files
histoire il fait rire à madame y sort en
nuisette pour sortir ses poubelles
[Rires]
là où est mon corps est déjà arrivé jean
marc griffin écouté mon sort et henri
salvador
les éboueurs de cette reprise
trouver
écoutez parole que lada octobre
je suis et power
on s'est trompé
[Musique]
bien ce monde
le fond
bien regarder
et nous
on vient nettoyer
[Musique]